This is pretty interesting from a Joe Rogan
episode earlier this week. Now, I know that
a lot of people want to talk about Joe Rogan
say he's saying he'd vote for Trump over Biden.
That's a different story. That's not today's
topic.
I hope to be able to talk to Joe personally
about the Trump Biden thing soon. But for
today, I want to play some clips for you of
Republican Congressman Dan Krenshaw on Joe
Rogan's program earlier this week. And in
the context of coronavirus. They got to talking
about health care. And Dan Krenshaw rolled
out just about every bad argument about health
care. And what I really like about this is
how Joe Rogan ended up kind of de facto destroying
the arguments that Dan Krenshaw was making.
But in a way that was just completely genuine.
It wasn't calculated with talking points.
And what I mean by that is Joe Rogan is more
of a political hobbyist than a political analyst.
And he even said recently, when I say I think
I'd vote Trump over Biden. I don't know what
I'm talking about. And he actually said, go,
you know, listen to people. He actually listed
The David Pakman Show. Go listen to people
who really are doing this full time. He doesn't
consider himself a political expert. I dub
it more of a political hobbyist. And Joe has
said many times politics is not his main thing.
He's interested in it. He has opinions. He
talks to people, but he's not a politics guy.
So what's interesting to me about the clips
that I'm going to play for you is that Dan
Krenshaw is making bad argument after bad
argument arguments that have a lot of history
in different political circles as being the
types of talking points you want to use. And
Joe dismantles them, not bike trotting out
his own crafted talking points, but just by
kind of reacting in real time with common
sense to the nonsense that Dan Krenshaw was
saying. So let's get right into it. I think
you'll find this interesting. First here is
Dan Krenshaw trotting out a popular argument
from libertarians, including people like Rand
Paul, which says Medicare for all or single
payer reduces freedom and it sort of enslaves
doctors. They argue we're not free with Medicare
for all. And Joe Rogan makes pretty quick
work of it.
And you'll see Dan Krenshaw become visibly
confused and sort of start jumping around
with non-sequiturs, trying to retort, but
failing when he would talk about Medicare
for all it tries to it tries to move past
these essential foundations, whether well
of a free society that we have to adhere to.
And and because the other thing I push back
on a little bit is, is the health care is
a right statement. And I push back against
that because what that when you're calling
something a right, what you're effectively
saying is that somebody else has a obligation
to serve you. And it's hard to call something
a right when that right requires the service
of somebody else.
Don't be picky. Don't you to do that with
the fireman. Don't do that with the police
department. Don't we do that with public schools?
Not not not exactly. No. I mean, we have public
services that I would I would distinguish
those public services from something like
a rex. Quality of care. And I would distinguish
into it to an enormous extent, like here's
why you can add a few hundred thousand more
people to a you know, to to the nation's population.
And it doesn't change the mission of the military.
Right. Like it doesn't it doesn't taken away
thing away from them. But these but because
of this sort of non rival is like an an an
an economics term for this sort of non rival
attribute of these things. It is different.
Right. Because there's only a select number
of doctors. And we've already said that once
you put price controls in, there's going to
be less doctors because doctors will be paid
less. You'll get burned out more. They'll
then possibly we'll be able to. And I actually
never finish that point.
So Dan tries to slip in. This is an economic
term implying, you know, a lot of people don't
know this term, but this is an old libertarian
argument. That's a really bad argument. So
so here's the deal. Single payer doesn't make
doctors slaves and it doesn't take away freedom.
In fact, we already have the Emergency Medical
Treatment and Active Labor Act, which mandates
that hospitals must provide stabilizing emergency
treatment to patients in a dire emergency
situation or delivery services to a woman
who is in active labor. Period. No matter
whether they can pay or not, no matter whether
they have insurance, if you're an E.R. doctor
and someone comes in with an emergency, you
must give them stabilizing treatment. This
has been around 34 years since 1986. Back
then, you had some people saying you're enslaving
doctors, but you're not. And it's a bad argument.
Consider lawyers. Everyone has a right to
an attorney. Even if you can't afford one,
you have a right to an attorney. Our attorneys,
slaves. Are attorneys enslaved by that? No.
Now, does any one lawyer have to take a certain
case? No. Typically not. Does any one doctor
have to treat a specific patient under single
payer?
No more than the general responsibility to
the Hippocratic Oath and to provide emergency
stabilizing treatment which dates back 34
years. Bad argument. Let's continue.
The reason price controls reduce supply and
the reason we see supply reductions in other
countries is because while hospitals don't
get the same amount of money, they're not
going invest in that extra ICU, but they're
not going to buy those extra ventilators.
They're not going to hire those other doctors.
A doctor doesn't want to be a doctor because
they don't make the amount of money that they
thought they would make. They're doing extra
work because there's more people who now have
access to them, but there's less of them.
So wait lines are huge and they and they're
seeing multiple more patients a day. Doctor
burnout increases quite a bit. That's the
quick answer as to why, why, why that happens.
But that can answer a question.
Now, here, I really need you to understand
this is a gift. Gallup Dan Krenshaw is throwing
about four to five different arguments that
Joe Rogan, none of it makes sense. None of
them are actually arguments against single
payer. And now he's moved beyond single payer
and is starting to talk about reimbursement
rates. Doctor compensation, that's one issue.
Many countries have successful systems, but
they've got to figure out doctor compensation.
That's that's just one issue. Then Dan Krenshaw
throws single payer will increase demand and
every hospital is going to be full. That's
an old tired argument. When you give everyone
health care, it doesn't increase demand. In
total, it shifts demand from people using
emergency rooms and waiting until things are
more serious to people going and getting checked
out earlier, going to their PSP instead of
the E.R.. And that actually can in many ways
lighten the load on emergency rooms and emergency
care and reduces the serious conditions because
people get checked out earlier. So Dan Krenshaw
here makes so many different arguments in
30 seconds that it's hard to keep up. Now,
let's skip forward to Joe reacting to this.
We're getting really that does Zebo. Yeah.
The human right issue. We we kind of moved
around with that. This idea that it's different
than the fire department or the police department
or.
Well, it's not a right either.
Actually, the fire departments, not necessarily
a a right as we would, but it's a public service
that's provided to everyone.
It is, but it but but it but understand. So
let's call it a public service then and let's
call doctor. Health care, a public service.
OK. If we were to do Medicare for all.
But wouldn't the result be the same if it's
provided for everyone?
Not not from a practical standpoint, just
because it's much easier. Again, you could
add a hundred thousand people more to your
city and the fire department would have marginally
more, more work to do.
Dan Krenshaw says not from a practical standpoint,
but actually, yes, Joe is right. It would
be the same thing. From a practical standpoint,
it would be different from an ideological
standpoint where, you know, Dan Crenshaw's
ideology makes health care different than
being a firefighter. But in practical terms,
it is basically the same thing as Joe Rogan
points out. Let's skip ahead a little now.
And this is just bad from Dan Krenshaw. And
Dan does something slippery. Dan starts talking
about socialism as a system more broadly rather
than just talking about health care. Joe's
talking about health care. And then this is
just amazing. Remember how in the clip I played
for you, Joe Rogan was saying health care
for everyone as a public service or a right
or whatever you call it. It's like firefighting.
It's like police or public education or whatever.
And back five minutes earlier, Dan Crenshaw
argued, no, no, no, health care is different.
Now, in this clip, only a few minutes have
gone by and Crenshaw says no Medicare for
all. Isn't socialism. It's a public good.
That's right, Dan.. That's what Joe said five
or six minutes earlier when you said, no,
it's different. Take a look.
What we're talking about over when you're
talking about socialism overall, not just
overall. I'm not just involving medicine.
You're talking about socialism in general.
And I'm saying, isn't the fire department
an example of socialism that works?
Well, often not an example of socialism. I
think it's an example of a public good, the
way the military is, an example of a public
good, the way the highways are, examples of
public goods, the way parks are exam.
Right. But they are funded by the people.
It's funded by people overall. It doesn't
cost people money to use them. And the people
have these as a basic part of our society
and our civilization.
Dan Crenshaw is just a human pretzel here.
He's completely wound up into knots. When
Joe says it's a public goods like these others,
Crenshaw says, no, it's different. Five minutes
later, when Rogan's says, aren't we socializing
an element of the economy and an element of
society that works fine to socialize, Crenshaw
says. No, no, no, no. It's not socialism.
It's merely a public good. Well, OK. Why didn't
you agree with Joe when he said that five
minutes earlier? Here's Crenshaw's last reaction.
And Krenshaw Crenshaw, he basically white
flags and he plays these pedantic semantic
games and says at the end, in the end, these
are really just semantic issues.
Now, I understand that and I'm nothing. No.
Pro-Mitt that I just I just would not call
them socialists.
Well, I would call the fire department. How
does it get funded?
It's it's a public housing get funded. It's
a public good. It gets funded by the public.
Right. And it just it's not but it's not relying
on these sort of. It's not relying on the
tenets of socialism to function. And so now
right now, we're kind of having a discussion
of definitions. And and this is an important
discussion to have because oftentimes even
Democrats aren't really talking about socialism.
Well, even during you know, Larry Sanders
doesn't call it socialism. He's talking about
democratic socialism. And he makes some very
clear distinctions between the two of them,
which I think you could apply to things like
the fire department or the police department.
Yeah. There's a lot in that.
So there's a lot there and I'm not going to
subject you to more of this, but I like this
for a few different reasons. Number one, they
try to stake ideological claims when they
can. But when Joe Rogan breaks down those
claims with simple questions, they retreat
to semantic games and geesh galloping, which
is just throwing out so many different assertions
that it becomes very difficult to keep track
of them and actually refute them one by one.
That's a sign that the facts aren't on your
side. But number two, you all know I've been
critical of some elements of Medicare for
all plants. There are issues around cost estimates
and other issues with a lot of these plans.
I would actually love it if the left and right
could simply agree on what we know, which
is Medicare for all will increase access and
Medicare for all can maintain or increase
quality. The question is at what cost will
we be able to maintain quality and increase
access to 100 percent? The corona virus stimulus
has proven when we want to, we can find 2
trillion. We can find 6 trillion. We can find
10 trillion if we want to. The money is there
if we decide we are going to do it. I would
much rather be able to move past these childish
arguments that Dan Crenshaw's laying out,
which Joe Rogan exposes as really very bad
arguments. Let's get our hands dirty and do
the nitty gritty work of figuring out how
this can all work, because it can work. It's
a question of at what cost and how to best
optimize it.